is that hungry dress yes so you're gonna
film this [ __ ] walks in ok what do I do
do I stand up on its a seated thanks
hello my sweet to me young Kira how are
you thanks how are you very well thank
you I bet you'd leave and yeah I was
pretty much hundred percent leave
feeling proud feeling proud about how
you bet did you know taught me through
as much as the cliche goes we are
stronger in Europe I genuinely believe
we are stronger in Europe stronger
together so an so you tell me why you
don't yeah there was the sovereign
children and also immigration but not
the way think I didn't think the
immigration system is fair I didn't
think it was fair that you know in the
EU you're from your side B you can come
in I'd like to see it easier people
outside the EU to come in because
they're lots of skilled people get
turned out immigration I feel there is
no doubt we have an immigration problem
yeah on our hands and you know the
numbers going up we only have so many
resources I don't feel living EU would
stop that issue I thought our border
controllers is a UK as a country issue
it's not I'm sorry without keys you know
the numbers even when we leave it's the
numbers are still quite big so
supposedly I'm not fastened me it's
about 40 of quantity sure that's it
exactly it seemed a lot more reasonable
I expected thank you I was worried you
were gonna shout at me and you know i'm
not saying i don't think that you use
perfect i don't think the UK is perfect
by any means I think there's a lot of
improves to be done in both but I feel I
pair
and by working together we could have
could have made that better my
ex-girlfriend actually was it was a
Romania and our fathers were quite
different not just in that respect but
in many respects but she was open-minded
as open-minded and we agree to disagree
i think the worst nightmare would be
someone who's so close mind that don't
want to consider I think so yes honest
I'm open-minded doubt don't have to
agree with me but just as long as its
civil about it and you know don't make
assumptions about me just because I've
only do you think as a young person I
inherently should not vote to lead the
agent the EU is inherently good for
young people I've heard that a lot um
yeah I do believe and fraud as a
generational thing I think it's good for
what it provides you know we're going
into the working world paid holiday paid
sick maternity but then we have my life
before yeah i'm not saying i'm right so
i can you not see that a young person
did vote to remain I think it's more of
an identity thing I think I obviously
believe I understand I understand
perfectly musical about the main I'm not
saying if you broke remained you're
silly because obviously there were
different reasons I just don't
understand why is young people in
particular you can feel so attached to
it why not that's not for watching
nothing wasn't it we don't quite fussy
eaters home oh yeah that was really good
I've exam for the brownie I've got it so
most no strawberries just cream oh you
did it yeah is fussy that's not the
woman's job to be fun I'm always I'm
always the funniest stuff and care okay
i have my friends that like go to
restaurants lower iboga just plain boat
you're the one like it very minus this
do that oh yeah good nice nice to meet
you is always one yep I'd like to meet
someone who voted to leave who can say I
voted to leave and this is why and
actually I think that's good rather than
just a headline I've heard on the Sun
before and thought you haven't done much
for yourself okay so why do you think
there's been a rise in hate crimes since
the brexit boat obviously don't know
I think dash shoes that were there thank
you were there already clearly I don't
think it's great a her thing something
people who have been no racist and
Prejudice now but suddenly you're
perfect on me before but at the same
time I do you think maybe it's been a
bit exaggerated okay that's why do you
think what in the media yeah exactly i
think these these issues were all be
there before remains and leavers i think
it was up i think that a few weeks
whether it really was polarizing but i
think that i think it people are calm
down to it now and i think actually
people just get on but in a professore
british way we sort of get on then I
don't think actually it is polarizing a
summer make out tell me why I should be
optimistic I shouldn't worry I didn't
win but why should I be able to look
firstly doesn't matter does it doesn t
matter what you or I think it's
happening it's happening you can't stop
it so what I'd say it oddly vote or
remain voters is that it's done you
can't change it stop whining and and try
and make this deal Best bristle when the
EU is collapsed and it will okay it's
gonna happen okay then I think it
telling your son he'll be you've been
texting me or message me on Facebook
whoever said yet you were right then
well I ok so just don't forward to that
debate well you then have what you got
first thing but I think I think I think
you've got to be up to missed it you
know it was weak let you say you can't
complain you can't whine you can't mine
it's helping it's done yeah that's that
ten years time when he use four laps
you'll see them right I still would vote
if we had the referendum tomorrow still
about how i did not as i still believe
same on certain issues but it was great
to speak on on and on a nice owner and a
friendly level with somebody who was it
out who was very modest about it and was
someone who understood the sort of
intellectual arguments because up here
which is very basic stuff i think both
of us we knew Luke BPD action we
actually knew about things you know
something headed but i think both you
know what we're talking about so that
helps I've learned that there actually
some some chilled-out people about the
outfit they're not all is loud and proud
and out there as the ones that I've so
far I've met have been yeah that's Sam
simile I think not all mean a lot most
my friends they were arraigned vocht as
emotional far less reason and care
just say that so when they see this that
you know they'll know that actually she
was much more pieces it and what we
looked at reasonable this wasn't you
know with my spectrum pretty good yeah
did you do this kind of thing again yeah
that's fine yeah premier laughing free
dinner quite the plane so nice hmm I
just don't want you to come for what
it's worth I think I think looks
stunning so oh that's very kind of you
I'll say nice things about you